[Applaudissements]
voilà Samuel qui est avec vous
j'aimerais qu'on voit là la vidéo juste
avant parce que on était avec Maître
cerussier Samuel on n'a pas pu voir mais
c'est vrai que je vous dis on l'a pas
mis jusqu'à la fin parce que c'est trop
voilà regardez c'est incroyable
[Applaudissements]
alors on a on a coupé la vidéo sachez-le
parce que voilà c'est c'était vraiment
très très choquant merci Samuel d'être
là merci à mettre ces roussi d'être là
également
vous avoir invité non mais ça c'est
vraiment ça va être un témoignage encore
très fort ce soir je vous dis je sais
bientôt la fin de la saison et cette
émission on l'a fait aussi pour ça et on
a vraiment des témoignages très forts
cette émission et Samuel merci d'être là
parce que Samuel c'est incroyable ce qui
ce qui s'est passé comment tu vas déjà
je vais très mal je vais très très mal
je ils m'ont détruit ils m'ont
totalement détruit voilà je suis à
miraculé de la vie et comment tu es
physiquement déjà physiquement je suis
mal et donc entre ce cervicale comment
il se crânien genou genou pété enfin
c'est très très dur en tout cas de
d'être de ouf mais je suis en tout cas
pour pour dénoncer on va revenir sur ce
qui s'est passé c'était le vendredi 24
mars dernier
tu vas en boîte de nuit près de
Marseille pour fêter l'anniversaire
d'une de tes amis du coup la du travail
très très bonne soirée et à la fin ben
voilà je la fin de la soirée à la fin de
la soirée je sors de la boîte de nuit
pour rejoindre ta voiture sur le parking
non je préfère je sors pour pour une
cigarette voilà tranquille ou voilà avec
les collègues et ce qui est assez je
tombe année avec de de barbares quoi de
barbares et qui me disent ça de guerre
répétition
je ne réponds pas parce que donc tu sors
tu es tranquillement en train de fumer
je sors de la boîte c'est là la boîte
avec ta copie
c'est que il me disait
[Musique]
le point abattre voilà par rapport à ça
et ben non en fait non en fait non je
non je suis pas d'accord avec ça et là
je veux d'accord avec ça donc là
qu'est-ce qui va dès que tu sors et
comment je sors voilà il se fasse ça et
je leur dis foutez-moi la paix
foutez-moi la plaie et et là on ne sait
pas du coup on va on reste sur le
parking et là je fume une cigarette je
suis énervé j'ai des collègues et là
il se passe ce qui se passe quoi il y a
rien entre le moment où donc tu sors la
boîte il t'invictive derrière direct ils
prennent la voiture et il traverse comme
ça c'est non enfin c'est c'est une
insulte et insulté m'insulte et ce cas
c'est qu'il y a une salle altercation
du coup voilà je on nous sépare on nous
sépare j'étais voilà j'étais au parking
avec avec du monde et ce qu'il y a c'est
que voilà
c'est est-ce que le trou noir aussi
parce que voilà j'étais un peu alcoolisé
quand vous étiez un peu alcoolisé oui
voilà mais bon c'est pas voilà mais
voilà c'est juste que voilà c'est c'est
ce qui m'arrivait ça voilà
juste après
voilà vous juste avant vous vous
attendiez pas à vous faire insulter non
complètement gratuitement non donc vous
lui répondez je réponds oui je réponds
je réponds je réponds parce que oui
parce que
parce que c'est bon stop quoi au bout
d'un moment parce que je j'ai ça depuis
mon enfance et je non c'est c'est trop
en fait c'est intro oui là c'était un
trou pour moi oui quoi est-ce que vous
l'insultez vous aussi oui vous
l'insulter vous aussi oui bien sûr parce
que au bout d'un moment j'ai la
lâchez-moi quoi là chez moi et puis
voilà moi je t'ai rien demandé donc
lâche-moi quoi lâche-moi je t'ai rien
demandé et puis là je crois quoi et là
il y a quoi il y a une ça chauffe entre
vous ça chauffe et on va le nous on ne
sait pas et après voilà
vous vendez donc là vous
êtes encore avec vos potes vous allez
plus loin tranquille pour me mettre vous
voyez la voiture arriver comme ça
je me souviendrai et donc là vous rien
du tout souvenez de rien non je me
souviens de rien non je non
vous avez revu les images j'ai vu les
images j'ai vu la vidéo je l'ai pas vu
il y a un mois ça parce que j'étais
suite à mes deux semaines mes trois
semaines de grossit
j'étais appris là je suis actuellement
dans le clinique de repos pour voilà
donc psychiatrique pour me remettre de
tout ça et là je suis encore je sortis
mais là il faut que j'ai encore besoin
parce que oui ils m'ont détruit et je
coupe aussi ben voilà je quand on voit
la violence je vous dis la vidéo on se
dit pour moi
il voulait il voulait
absolument et elle carcation leader les
sépare et après ils font le tour en
voiture il s'est pressé de l'après
méditation c'est il vit Samuel et à
cette vitesse là avec une voiture qui
est une arme c'est pour vous tuer ah oui
clairement ils m'ont vu ils m'ont vu ils
m'ont vu je pense clairement en boîte
ils ont vu comment j'étais habillé ils
ont vu que voilà que j'étais un talon et
tout et j'étais la prof facile pour eux
c'était la pro facile et ils ont vu ils
ont vu que je partais la boîte et hop
j'étais le point abattre alors Gilles
pour raconter l'histoire vraiment à des
inspecteurs c'est vrai que c'est mal
voilà la raconter mais voilà ça me est
en boîte de nuit une soirée festive qui
se passe bien et à un moment il sort
fort et puis il est invectivé par ces
deux personnes qui l'invective voilà qui
commence à l'insulter ça le gai voilà à
ce moment-là et donc ces gens là
l'insulte il ne répond pas et je crois à
la troisième fois vous commencez à
répondre c'est ce que j'ai vu dans le
dossier il commence à répondre une
altercation leader les sépare Samuel lui
il pense que c'est terminé mauvaise
soirée gâcher un peu mais terminé et là
les deux personnes font le tour en
voiture et reviennent sur lui et fonce
sur sa main qui est projeté comme un
fétu de paille et qui s'en sort
miraculeusement et qui va être
hospitalisé alors là c'est vrai que
quand on voit la scène on se dit
vraiment ils ont voulu vous tuer vous
vous réveillez à l'hôpital qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce que vous dites le comment vous
réveillez ce que vous savez pourquoi
vous êtes là ce que vous vous souvenez
de quelque chose ou rien du tout je me
souviens de enfin je me souviens être
trou noir et puis je me suis appris mes
parents mes parents qui étaient là pour
moi c'était pour moi c'était c'était
pour moi c'était un cauchemar quoi un
cauchemar
ils étaient alcoolisé les deux je ne
sais pas je ne sais pas et je m'en fous
et je
traumatisme crânien fracture du rocher
en tors cervicale hématome un peu
partout vous avez eu unité de 13 jours
vous avez encore des séquelles
alors mettre ces roussi merci d'être là
juste qu'on a tous envie de savoir si
on en est où
alors on en est où on en est que la
justice il faut le reconnaître ça allait
très vite il y a deux personnes qui ont
été interpellées une a été placée enfin
les deux ont été placés en garde à vue à
la suite de cela une des deux a été
placée en détention provisoire
conducteur et la seconde est ce contrôle
judiciaire il s'agit de deux jeunes de
21 22 ans qui a priori préparé une fuite
à l'étranger au moment où ils ont été
interpellés le matin par par la police
nationale vous savez Cyril si je peux me
permettre vous avez montré une partie de
la vidéo et je sais que mon avis il y a
des contraintes visuelles qui qui vous
importe ne pas le montrer jusqu'au bout
mais c'est vrai que comme le sujet qui
était évoqué juste avant avec cette
mamie et sa petite fille c'est vrai que
on a d'un côté le poids des mots le choc
des photos aujourd'hui il est froid des
vidéos c'est ça parce que cette histoire
finalement elle n'est aujourd'hui sur
votre plateau elle n'est finalement à la
une de tous les médias que parce qu'il y
a quelqu'un qui prend son téléphone tu
vois c'est qui voit cette intercréation
et qui commence à filmer et on se dit
que ben voilà un peu comme disait Gilles
Verdez on est dans un froid incroyable
on est dans une gradation qui ne
s'arrête plus on plus ce qui va arriver
aujourd'hui on ouvre le cabinet au matin
on ne sait pas ce qui va se passer on a
des motifs de plus en plus futiles des
agressions de plus en plus barbares des
blessures qui sont totalement
incroyables des gens qui sont amputés
des gens qui meurent malheureusement on
a des fusillades dans tous les sens
aujourd'hui on ouvre le journal et on se
dit finalement à qui le tour et c'est
incroyable et aujourd'hui Samuel a la
chance d'être devant vous mais c'est
vrai que pour ceux qui ont vu la vidéo
jusqu'au bout et je sais qu'ici tout le
monde l'a vu on se demande comment c'est
possible que ce garçon soit ici présenté
c'est incroyable on va expliquer la
vidéo Gilles la vidéo en fait il y a ça
et puis après il tente de le de
l'écraser quoi de le tuer voilà ils
reviennent on a l'impression qu'il
s'acharnent ils veulent en faire
effectivement une victime ils veulent
vous tuer ils veulent vous tuer non
justement c'est une tentative
d'assassinat non il y a pas de débat
pour moi vous savez la différence entre
le meurtre l'assassinat c'est l'après
méditation et pour ma part il y a aucun
doute Gilles Verdez le disait juste
titre pour moi la prémilitation est
caractérisée il y a pas de débat c'est
une tentative d'assassinat pour moi il y
a une préméditation et vous savez que la
tentative en France est plus de la même
façon que l'acte s'il avait été commis
aujourd'hui il y a une réalité il sorte
il a le temps de fumer une deux trois
cigarettes sur le parking vous le voyez
il y a plus rien qui se passe sur la
vidéo on le voit il y en a trop de monde
de jeunes tout le monde discute on a
l'impression que tout est terminé à tort
malheureusement finalement ils vont
revenir et ce qui me rend fou dans cette
vidéo Cyril c'est que vous le voyez il y
a en fait il y a tout qui va pas en fait
il y a rien qui va ils reviennent et
vous voyez ce petit coup de volant la
voiture qui est sur la gauche finalement
il y a une vraie volonté il avait
jusqu'à la dernière seconde pour se dire
ben finalement je vais pas aller
jusqu'au bout et vous le voyez il freine
il fait une sorte de rodéo urbain et
tourne sur lui-même il revient dans sa
direction il a la possibilité de
l'éviter et au contraire au lieu de
mettre un coup de vol à droite il en met
à gauche et vous le voyez la suite de la
vidéo ben on peut la raconter peut-être
il y a un saut en l'air de plus de 3
mètres il retombe sur la tête un trauma
crânien gravissime une fracture du crâne
son genou qui est complètement exploser
aujourd'hui vous l'avez dit il avait
aucun antécédent psychiatrique étant
clinique de repos il a besoin de se
reconstruire c'est quelqu'un qui
travaille qui n'a pas d'antécédents
judiciaire qui avait déjà porté plainte
à plusieurs reprises pour homophobie ça
n'avait jamais été suivi des faits
aujourd'hui heureusement que la justice
s'en est saisi les choses ont l'air
d'avancer rapidement mais c'est vrai
qu'il faut dénoncer alors c'est vrai
qu'il faut aussi constater que on est
endommagé alors pour noter les
spectateurs qui nous rejoindre à 21h04
vous avez tous vu cette vidéo vraiment
qui est insoutenable de Samuel et de ses
agresseurs ils sont deux ils sont deux
agresseurs alors il y a deux agresseurs
en réalité si vous voulez là tout le
débat qui va être celui du procès ça va
être concrètement le rôle du passager
c'est ça parce que finalement alors
Samuel il y a quelques jours me disait
mais vous savez moi je suis je suis très
contrarié parce que le passager n'est
que sous contrôle judiciaire en
extérieur alors justement parce que
qu'est-ce qui se passe avec le juste on
n'a pas dit ce qui se passait avec le
conducteur le conducteur est détention
provisoire d'accord aujourd'hui il est
incarcéré dans l'attente de son procès
il risque quoi vous savez
s'il y a une tentative d'assassinat sur
tentative d'assassinat avec une
circonstance aggravante puisque
aujourd'hui l'homophobie c'est ce qu'on
va plaider c'est ce qu'on va démontrer
c'est ce qu'on va mettre en avant c'est
la perpétuité si vous voulez voilà des
peines sont gravissime et il faut un
moment aller au bout parce qu'en France
aujourd'hui la percute plus rien dire
rien ça mêle t'inquiète la permaculture
aujourd'hui les peines finalement elles
sont
les peines finalement elles sont
prononcées elles sont plus ou moins
exécutées lorsqu'elles sont pas
exécutées finalement tout à l'heure vous
le disez il y a des gens qu'on retrouve
dans la rue des gens qu'on retrouve dans
le métro qui n'ont rien à faire dans la
rue et aujourd'hui ils ont été retrouvés
assez vite ils ont été retrouvés assez
vite puisque la voiture n'était pas
volée l'immatriculation a été si vous
voulez ça a été relativement rapide et
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que vous ne
le voyez pas sur cette vidéo il
semblerait d'après les témoignages qu'on
a recueilli qui sont revenus
immédiatement sur l'accident pour
essayer de l'achever au sol c'est ça qui
est incroyable enfin l'achever avec ce
véhicule aujourd'hui ce n'est pas
que ils ont fait brûler le véhicule
c'est ça c'est à dire qu'ils ont pris
conscience de ce qu'ils avaient fait ils
ont voulu un moment partir à l'étranger
ils ont fait brûler la voiture pour
éliminer les preuves je crois simplement
c'est bien ça vous connaissez le dossier
que moi
je te voyais hocher la tête par rapport
au sort du passager pour toi c'est c'est
pareil pour moi c'est intolérable qui
soit qui soit sauvé en judiciaire qui
pour moi et pour moi il met la prison
pour moi renfermé quoi c'est il était
dans la voiture voilà il a la
possibilité de partir ben non il avait
une mafia à plusieurs reprises quoi il a
et on voit clairement que sur la vidéo
que c'était à la reprise quoi donc pour
moi non c'est ce mec là il est il doit
il doit aussi impayé quoi
aujourd'hui en pays en pays les frais
comme comme le conducteur
malheureusement pour moi là je vis avec
c'est dur ce que c'est dur parce que
dans le mec il est en liberté et moi je
moi je suis bizarre quoi toi ta vie elle
est gâchis ma vie elle est gâchée
et vous avez peur qu'ils viennent se
venger sur vous de
ma famille
aucun des deux n'est connu de service de
police non pour l'instant on n'a pas on
n'a pas lancé
au début de
ton arrivée ici tu me dis ma vie est
gâcher ma vie ton quotidien depuis cette
agression alors je suis actuellement
un clic de repos donc psychiatrique
alors que tu t'étais pas du tout suivi
non et non alors
détruit moi ma personnalité il
mentalement détruit j'étais joyeux j'ai
j'ai mis la vie quoi j'ai mis la vie
j'ai mes amis j'aimais ma famille là il
manque un engagé et là je suis en colère
des fois je me connais plus je mets ta
vie elle est pas gâchée elle est pas
gâchée c'est un moment difficile mais
ça veut qu'on doit gâcher
pour l'instant je vois pour l'instant en
fait mais bien sûr prends le temps de te
reposer mais dis-toi que on sait c'est
très dur je peux pas imaginer ce que tu
as vécu parce que c'est tellement
violent les images moi je les avais pas
vu personnellement et je veux pas voir
la suite
tu vas te relever sache que il va
peut-être falloir des mois prendre le
temps qu'il faut mais ta vie elle va pas
s'arrêter parce que tu vas pas les
laisser gagner
comme toutes les victimes d'homophobie
et d'autres choses peu importe
ne doivent pas finalement perdre face à
la violence de toutes ces personnes là
je voudrais juste rappeler les chiffres
rapidement comme ça c'est toujours
important quand même de les dire en 2022
184 agressions physiques soit une tous
les deux jours en hausse de 28% par
rapport à 2021 si on continue à ce
rythme-là jusqu'à où on va aller c'est
clairement un fléau national il y en a
qui essaie de le minimiser c'est pas
minimisable faut que ça soit clair et
donc tu vas te relever tu vas voir ça va
aller t'assure je vais aussi montrer aux
personnes exactement que c'est des
preuves malheureusement moi j'en ai une
et il faut se relever
toute mon enfance a été toute ma vie
scolaire qu'on en parle on en parler à 4
ans de ça mais non ça existe toujours
moi ça toujours existé depuis mon
enfance c'était homophobie et la semence
scolaire tous les jours tous les jours
quoi que je fasse je le faisais rien je
t'aimerai les les revoir
ces deux abrutis j'ai envie de dire
que c'est pas il y a pas d'autres mots
qu'est-ce que tu leur dirais
je leur dirais que que leur vie que leur
vie est en
est en prison et pas jusqu'à
aujourd'hui pour toi ton quotidien au
niveau physique est-ce que est-ce que tu
vas garder les séquelles ou pas
qu'est-ce qu'on dit oui moi je mange
genou qui n'est pas opérable je vais
j'ai beaucoup de séances de rééducation
oui dans syndical rééducation aussi
si je peux me permettre
je vais te dire on a tous vu l'agression
je peux te dire
le fait que tu sois en colère le fait
que tu me dises ma vie soit plus sera
plus jamais comme avant et que tu penses
qu'à une chose c'est que bien sûr ces
abrutis ils soient punis et paye pour ce
qu'ils ont fait mais moi je trouve que
si je peux donner un conseil je trouve
que durée tu devrais voir aussi le truc
de l'autre côté je te jure que quand on
voit moi j'ai vu les images en entier je
peux te dire ça meule miraculé mais
incroyable et je pense j'ai une force
d'avoir aussi vu la vidéo si je te le
dis alors bien sûr que tu as des
séquelles mais je trouve que les
séquelles elles sont pas j'aurais pu
voilà avoir des sixièmes bien sûr
beaucoup plus importante je trouve que
tu t'en sors très bien donc moi si
j'étais toi
et voilà
il faut que tu dises là maintenant il
faut que tu profites de la vie parce que
tu es un miraculé tu es voilà tu es
franchement tu vas pouvoir du bonus
exactement au contraire tu dois dire
merci quoi bien sûr je suis là
pour profiter de la vie vraiment et il
faut qu'on se retrouve le moral bien sûr
OK